jetzt wo wir auf den tagesordnungspunkt
24 das ist eine vereinbarte debatte zum
internationalen frauentag für die
aussprache wurde eine dauer von 60
minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne die aussprache und datei das
wort kollegin katja mast spd weil herr
präsident meine sehr verehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren wir brauchen
mehr gleichstellung gerade jetzt warum
gerade jetzt
warum gerade während der pandemie frauen
haben im home-office nicht die gleichen
bedingungen wie männer
die pandemie verstärkt alle roller
rollenverteilungen frauen verdienen
immer noch strukturell weniger als
männer frauen stehen in der
krisenbewältigung in vorderster reihe
aber leider nicht wenn es um
führungsverantwortung in der wirtschaft
geht
ich finde diese muster müssen wir
durchbrechen der kampf auch sagt an uns
alle für einen kulturwandel sorgen in
deutschland und in unseren unternehmen
schauen sie doch mal nach skandinavien
da geht führungen teilzeit dann klug
anreize für partnerschaftliche
vereinbarkeit das können wir doch auch
deutschland kann mehr
wir haben so viele tolle talentierte
frauen und doch sitzen die männer in den
machtpositionen weil hans
lieber hänschen fördert als anna diesen
zustand können wir nicht nehmen lassen
sie uns mehr ehrgeiz baden wird der weg
von dieser präsenzkultur von diesem
wichtig machen durch anwesenheit kluge
entscheidungen reifen doch in einem
erholten kopf also habe ich drei große
ziele aus erstens ich will dass die
2020er jahre das jahrzehnt der frauen
werden
wir müssen in allen bereichen unserer
gesellschaft den gleichstellungs turbo
zünden
ich will dass wir bis 2030 parität in
der politik erreichen wir brauchen mehr
frauen in allen parlamenten von
gemeinderat bisher zum bundestag es darf
keinen zweiten bundestag wie diesen
werden mit so wenig frauen und drittens
hellblauen gleichberechtigte teilhabe in
allen gesellschaftlichen bereichen
auch bei der arbeitsteilung in den
familien und die spd das wissen wir
reden nicht nur wir handeln also haben
wir in dieser koalition vorgelegt den
kinderbonus in der in der krise
unterstützen wir insbesondere familien
wir haben mit den gute kita gesetz
milliarden in die vereinbarkeit von
familie und beruf investiert mit unseren
ministerin
franziska giffey und christine lambrecht
führen wir endlich die erste vorstands
quote in der geschichte dieses landes
ein und letzte woche bringen wir die
gleichstellungs stiftung auf den weg
aber gleichstellungspolitik ist für uns
nicht nur frauensache
heiko maas macht für minister
außenpolitik hubertus heil bringt
konkret hubertus heil bringt konkret die
grundrente auf den weg und kämpft für
ordentliche löhne und perspektiven in
der pflege olaf scholz kämpft mit uns
für einen mindestlohn von mindestens 12
euro vor all dem profitieren vor allem
frauen
dieser weg dieser weg ist für uns
verpflichtung schließlich hat unsere
partei vor über 100 jahren das
frauenwahlrecht erkämpft kommen sie
gehen sie mit uns diesen weg schritt für
schritt zu echter gleichstellung
[Applaus]
nächste gegnerin ist die kollegin maria
naber töne afd
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter präsident sehr geehrte
damen und herren wie in jedem jahr
bietet der weltfrauentag gelegenheit
bilanz zu ziehen
was hat sich für die frauen und mädchen
in deutschland verändert was zum guten
und was zum schlechten
die korona krise hat wie so viele krisen
kriege und naturkatastrophen zuvor
gezeigt dass frauen unverzichtbare
leistungsträger sind
und wenn man von linker seite hört krone
habe zu einem rückfall in alte
rollenbilder geführt dann ist das eine
untragbare abwertung der leistungen der
frauen und mütter in deutschland
genau das gegenteil ist der fall frauen
sind die helden von corona sie haben
nicht nur in systemrelevanten gerufen
zum beispiel in krankenhäusern
pflegeeinrichtungen kindergärten und im
lebensmittelhandel ihre frau gestanden
sie haben es auch geschafft die
doppelbelastung durch die betreuung
ihrer kinder zu hause und die
berufstätigkeit zu stemmen sie und nicht
die regierung haben das land am laufen
gehalten und zwar zusammen mit tollen
männern und vätern
das ist eine meisterleistung der frauen
der männer der familie in deutschland
und ganz gewiss kein rückfall in alte
rollenbilder als katastrophalen rückfall
in alte zeiten muss man viel mehr den
schlächtern verlust der freiheiten der
frauen in deutschland bezeichnen
freiheiten wie zuvor über jahrhunderte
erkämpft wurden die freiheit sich
jederzeit angstfrei ohne männliche
begleitung und in jedem beliebigen
stadtteil aufhalten zu können allein
joggen zu gehen sich kleine zu dürfen
wie man möchte und nicht schon als
kleines mädchen verschleiert zu werden
die freiheit sich sein ehemann selbst
auswählen zu dürfen nicht
zwangsverheiratet zu
oder ihn mit ex ehefrauen teilen zu
müssen
die freiheit keiner häuslichen gewalt
durch einen tyrannischen patriarchen
ausgeliefert zu sein
die freiheit zu entscheiden ob und
welchen beruf man ergreifen möchte ob
man sich seinen lebensunterhalt selbst
verdient oder nur zum einkaufen in
männlicher begleitung als unbezahlte
vollzeit dienerin verschleiert aus dem
haus gelassen wird und dass diese
freiheiten der frauen im deutschland des
21 jahrhunderts in gefahr sind das liegt
an ihrer politik der unbegrenzten
migration aus archaischen kultur konnten
durch ihr politisch korrektes
kultursensible schweigend machen sie
sich mit schuldig mitschuldig daran dass
die über jahrhunderte hart erkämpfen
freiheit und rechten der deutschen
frauen gefährdet sind kommende
generation werden ihre politik ganz
gewiss nicht bejubeln
aber statt sich der wahren probleme der
frauen in deutschland zu kümmern führten
sie auch in 2020 lieber von ton debatten
debatten über die gender gerechte
verhunzung der deutschen sprache über
unisex toiletten und immer wieder das
leidige thema frauenquote sie machen
frauen dort zu opfern wo sie gar keine
sind und sie schweigend laut dort wo sie
zunehmend zu opfern werden
und irgendwie kann ich das sogar
verstehen weil sie andernfalls ihre
existenzberechtigung verlieren würden
weil ihre linken utopien wie
kartenhäuser ineinander zusammenfallen
die utopie dass der kampf für
frauenrechte und massenmigration
kompatibel ist
feministischer multikulturalismus das
ist wie ein vegetarischer schlachthof
fern jeder lebenswirklichkeit
stattdessen sollten sich an die wahre
bedeutung des weltfrauentags erinnern an
den guten und richtigen kampf echter
frauenrechtlerin und an die erfolge
dieses kampfes freiheit schutz vor
gewalt gleichberechtigung
damit haben sie in deutschland des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts leider
genug zu tun denn all das steht im zuge
der von ihnen beförderten
massenmigration auf dem spiel
also öffnen sie endlich die probleme die
augen für die wahren probleme der frauen
in deutschland und handeln sie
entsprechend vielen dank
jetzt hab ich das wort der kollegin
nadine schön cdu csu sehr geehrter herr
präsident lieber kollegen kollegen
einsatz zu meiner vorrednerin natürlich
gelten frauenrechte und
gleichberechtigung für alle frauen in
unserem land und natürlich fordern wir
dass ein für die frauen die schon lange
hier leben genauso wie die frauen für
die frauen die jetzt neu zu uns kommen
die beregnung zu erleben am heutigen
weltfrauentag waffen wird natürlich den
klick auf die frauen in der krise und
frauen in der krise das sind die
superheld ihnen die hauptschule pflege
der schwiegermutter und das schrubben
der prüfung mittagessen alles
miteinander vereinbaren alles zusammen
gleichzeitig immer noch ein bisschen
mehr
und das seit einem jahr frauen in der
krise da sind die für die wir klatschen
die in den heimen in den
pflegeeinrichtungen in den
krankenhäusern menschen betreuen pflegen
heilen und leider auch viel zu oft
sterben sehen
75 prozent der angestellten im
gesundheitssektor sind frauen im
pflegebereich sogar 85 prozent frauen in
der krise
das sind ja auch die ausgebremsten
mütter die mehr betreuungsaufgaben
übernommen haben als die väter in vielen
fällen wobei natürlich auch die eine
menge geleistet haben und die und dass
es interessant laut studien des
jobportals linkedin derzeit sich
deutlich weniger auf kreative stellen
bewerben als dass männer tun und das im
tatsachen die muss man einfach zur
kenntnis nehmen frauen in der krise das
sind teilweise auch die zukurzgekommenen
nämlich unglaublich viele minijobber in
den dia keinen anspruch auf
kurzarbeitergeld haben frauen in der
krise das sind oft auch opfer die den
fluss der partner abgekommen
wir sehen beim
telefon gegen gewalt an frauen einen
anstieg von 20 prozent und das sind ja
auch nur die die sich trauen sich
tatsächlich hilfe zu suchen und frauen
in der krise das sind auch die
seniorinnen die witwe die allein ersteht
alleinstehenden die viele wochen und
monaten auf umarmen auf einen händedruck
auf ein gutes gespräch verzichten
mussten und frauen wehrten eben mal im
schnitt fünf jahre älter als männer
also gibt es auch viel mehr alte frauen
viel mehr widmen die besonders internets
dieser krise leiten
für uns alle für männer wie frauen war
das letzte jahr sehr verehrt aber nach
diesen zahlen wenn man es im vergleich
anschaut muss man schon sagen für frauen
war es besonders hart und besonders
anstrengend und warum sage ich das weil
ich will dass am montag am weltfrauentag
besonders laut gejammert werden darf
weil ich will dass wir mitleid bekommen
ich sage das heute hier raus weil ich
finde dass wir hier im bundestag in der
regierung und dass alle diejenigen
dienen diesen dann verantwortung tragen
an verschiedenen stellen in wirtschaft
und gesellschaft diejenigen die
entscheidungen treffen müssen daraus
ihre lehren ziehen müssen und dafür eine
verantwortung haben wir haben gemeinsam
die verantwortung dass wir die situation
für frauen in unserem land besser machen
und dafür dass die krise eben nicht
zurücktritt wird
lasst uns doch arbeit neu denken lasst
uns vereinbarkeit möglich machen nicht
mit starren modellen wie dem von
hubertus heil sondern mit kreativität
flexibilität und neuen lösungen
vertrauens arbeitszeiten home office
flexibilisiert und das wird vor allem
frauen ihrer arbeit mit familie besser
zu vereinbaren und wir haben doch
gesehen dass vieles möglich ist lassen
wir nicht zu dass dieses jahr für frauen
dauerhaft zum karriereknick wird die
frauen sind hier nicht weg sie haben nur
andere prioritäten und deshalb sorgen
wir gemeinsam dafür das kind und
karriere sich nicht ausschließen
durch die möglichkeit von führen in
teilzeit durch besser und flexibler
kinderbetreuung wir haben das gute kita
gesetz auf den weg gebracht und wir
fordern auf den west anspruch auf einen
betreuungsplatz unser gesetz für mehr
frauen in führungspositionen bringen wir
schnell auf den weg und wir unterstützen
dort schaffen der räume und zeiten auch
der erholung durch kuren für mütter und
frauen und andere möglichkeiten der
entlastung kämpfen der weiter für eine
bessere bezahlung in der pflege für
hauswirtschaft und erziehungs
tätigkeiten und tun wir etwas gegen
einsamkeit im alter
wir haben viele projekte modellprojekte
und auch die mehrgenerationenhäuser auf
den weg gebracht aber das reicht uns
nicht
wir wollen einen aktionsplan gegen
einsamkeit und flächendeckende ganz
konkrete maßnahmen sorgen wir dafür dass
opfern von häuslicher gewalt schnell
geholfen wird wir haben in dieser
legislaturperiode mit dem programm für
die frauenhäuser und die
beratungsstellen 120 millionen zur
verfügung gestellt und den runden tisch
geschaffen hier wollen wir weiter
arbeiten etwa auch beim thema
prostitution und vergessen wir die
frauen weltweit nicht diejenigen die
dafür dass wir schöne t shirts oder
günstige rosen haben auf den feldern
schuften müssen unter schlechten
bedingungen auch hier haben wir eine
verantwortung dass es auf diesen frauen
besser geht
liebe kolleginnen kollegen wir wollen
die schwärme wir wollen kein mitleid wir
wollen strukturen ändern und
gewohnheiten wir wollen dass frauen zu
gewinnerinnen der krise werten dann kann
die krise tatsächlich zu einer chance
für frauen in unserem land werden
[Applaus]
jetzt jetzt einig das war der kollegin
nicole bauer fdp
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte frau ministerin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen als ich 16
jahre war war es nicht klar ob ich
abitur mache ich war wissbegierig ich
wollte lernen und mir die türen öffnen
ich wollte meine zukunft gestalten
später entschied ich mich für das
ingenieurstudium weil nicht echt mit
innovation faszinierte weil ich neue
antriebe entwickeln wollte weil ich
unsere zukunft gestalten wollte und als
ich mich mit anfang 20 entschied in die
fdp einzutreten wollte ich mitreden
mitentscheiden ja ich wollte erneut
unsere zukunft gestalten und so wie es
mir geht jedes unzähligen jungen frauen
und mädchen da draußen hierzulande und
anderswo
wir frauen wollen unsere zukunft in der
politik mitgestalten in der wirtschaft
in der wissenschaft und in vielen
anderen bereichen
wir frauen wollen selbstbestimmt
entscheidungen treffen wann wie viele
und ob überhaupt kinder bekommen wir
wollen unsere träume und chancen
verwirklichen den aufstieg in eine
spitzenposition vielleicht sogar als
mama und managern und wir wollen unsere
talente einbringen in die künstliche
intelligenz programmierung von
algorithmen und wind der digitalen und
technologischen wandel
meine damen und herren unser zeichen
steht ganz klar auf neuausrichtung wie
euch lieber alles sind überzeugt davon
dass es nicht die frauen denn es sind
die sich anpassen müssen ein längst
überholtes es ist an uns an uns als
gesellschaft als parlament als
arbeitgeber neue formen neue rahmen zu
setzen für faire beste startchancen
verwirklichungschancen und
aufstiegschancen
denken wir also neu denken wir für
miteinander in vielfalt für einen
kulturwandel in parteien und unternehmen
ermöglichen wir mehr flexibilität doch
neue formen wie job sharing und top
sharing und sorgen wie endlich für welt
bildung in kitas und schulen unabhängig
vom eigenen elternhaus also blicken wir
nach vorne verabschieden wir uns aus der
zeit in der frauen von den männern sich
erklären lassen oder immer noch müssten
was ihre aufgabe werde oder dass sie
ungefragt das feedback zu ihrem
auftreten zu im ausgang oder zuhörer
stimme bekommt begegnen wir uns endlich
auf augenhöhe frauen haben er nicht erst
in der korona pandemie bewiesen dass die
augenhöhe und der respekt definitiv
angebracht ist respekt vor den vielen
frauen die namen supermarktkassen in den
kitas in den krankenhäusern altenheimen
jeden tag während der pandemien einsatz
brachten respekt vor den frauen die
jeden tag den spagat zwischen arbeit
lehrer ersatz und kinderbetreuung im
eigenen zuhause oder im betrieb
meisterten respekt vor den frauen wissen
denn die ihr land hervorragend führten
durch die pandemie respekt vor den
influenza und anderen frauen in der
öffentlichkeit in kunst und kultur in
ämtern und in medien respekt vor den
frauen die an der entwicklung von
impfstoffen beteiligt sind oder chef
biologinnen sind respekt vor den beiden
nobelpreisträgerinnen der krimi respekt
vor all den frauen die unsere zukunft
mitgestalten wie alles und meine
persönlichen heldinnen diesen jahres
ja und es gibt unzählige und es gebe
weitaus mehr wenn wir endlich den kurs
ändern damit wir alle unsere talente
verwirklichen können deshalb setzen wir
unsere stegen neu denken wir hier und
heute ist der richtige zeitpunkt für
diesen wandel
[Applaus]
cornelia möhring die linke ist die
nächste weg
sehr geehrter herr präsident kolleginnen
und kollegen gleichstellung
gerechtigkeit muss erkämpft werden sie
wird uns nicht gegeben
soziale und demokratische rechte sind
das ergebnis lange auseinandersetzungen
und gegner der kämpfenden und
streikenden frauen waren immer besonders
der adel das männliche bürgertum sowie
konservative und nationalisten
auch heute ist es die politische rechte
sind es die konservativen kräfte die
gleichstellung in dem moment ablegen wo
sie die eigene macht bedroht
der widerstand gegen die parität der
widerstand gegen die quoten zeugt von
dieser angst und auch heute ist es die
politische rechte die sich gegen eine
der grundlegendsten gleichstellungs
forderung stellt das recht über den
eigenen körper
die sexualität und fortpflanzung selber
zu entscheiden
und solange ärztin nicht selber über
ihre medizinischen leistungen
informieren dürfen solange frauen nicht
das recht haben über den abbruch oder
die austragung einer schwangerschaft
selber zu entscheiden wird es keine
wirkliche gleichstellung geben der 219 a
und der 218 müssen aus dem
strafgesetzbuch gestrichen werden
und weil ich die letzten frauenhaus
debatte in dieser wahlperiode ist einen
bemerken zu meinen eigentlich sehr
geschätzten spd-kollegin es gibt ein
paar punkte die nehme ich ihn wirklich
übel
besonders aber den hyde gang kompromiss
zum 219 a
sie haben der gleichstellung damit einen
bärendienst erwiesen und das hat auch
die debatte gestern zur sexuellen
selbstbestimmung doch erneut gezeigt ich
hoffe sehr dass sie das auch bis zur
bundestagswahl merken und andere in
diesem hause auch das mit der union
keine wirkliche gleichstellung möglich
ist und es auch zukünftig nie sein wird
gleichstellung soziale gerechtigkeit und
solidarität gehören nämlich zusammen
und weil rosa luxemburg heute ihren 150
geburtstag begeht ende ich mir
ihr anteil ihres zitates alles andere
ist quark mit einer kollegin um das haus
gut die sollen sich die grünen sehr
geehrter herr präsident meine damen und
herren heute erleben wir voraussichtlich
die letzte debatte zum internationalen
frauentag mit angela merkel als
kanzlerin
heute hätte ein tag sein können an dem
sie als kanzlerin und sie als
bundesregierung sich hätten dafür feiern
lassen können das sieges waren die mit
verkrusteten strukturen aufgeräumt und
der gleichberechtigung einen richtigen
schub nach vorne hätten geben können so
wie es in artikel 3 absatz 2 des
grundgesetzes gemeint ist mit dem
auftrag des status auch wenn dich der
opposition angehören
ich hätte ihnen diesen erfolg gegönnt
für die frauen und für die mädchen in
unserem land denn wir müssen so dringend
vorankommen in deutschland das sehen wir
jetzt so deutlich wie nie die pandemie
zeigt uns schmerzhaft als gesellschaft
auf dass der weg zu echter
gleichberechtigung noch weiter ist
dieser stillstand bei den
geschlechterverhältnissen kann
frustrieren dabei brauchen wir die
vielen frauen die sich in unserer
gesellschaft in den vielen frauen
organisationen aber auch in der kultur
und überall jeden tag neu engagieren und
für gleichberechtigung kämpfen wir
sollten ihren kampf hier abbilden und
als politik entschlossen handeln denn
was getan werden muss ist ziemlich klar
meine damen und herren wir haben kein
erkenntnisproblem sondern handlungs
problem diese verhaltens starre geht auf
kosten der frauen damit muss schluss
sein was zu tun wäre
können sie aktuell auch wieder im
wahlprogramm der spd lesen und in den
letzten tagen in den zeitungen dort
steht etwa dass sie das
ehegattensplitting abschaffen wollen
dass die paragraf 218 aus dem
strafgesetzbuch streichen wollen das
lesen wir absolute zustimmung zu diesen
forderungen aber warum erst jetzt
aufgefallen sie sind in der regierung
sie hätten das seit drei jahren angehen
können statt taten erleben wir viele
verzögerungen beim lang angekündigten
gleichstellungs institut zum beispiel
dass gerade gerade das hätte in der
aktuellen krise so wichtig sein können
und was kommt jetzt auf den letzten
drücker
das ist schade denn die forderung frauen
von anfang an der pandemie krise an den
tisch zu holen haben sie weder für sich
selber noch für die frauen und für die
forscherinnen zum beispiel gefordert und
das war ein echter fehler
oder nehmen wir die frage der
repräsentanz von frauen in der politik
der aktuelle frauenanteil liegt bei
unter einem drittel frauen 31 prozent
das ist beschämend niedrig und das
verlangt gesetzliche maßnahme auch hier
nichts passiert noch nicht mal eine
kommission die sich über jahre mit
diesen fragen auseinandersetzen soll ist
bisher eingesetzt wir grüne wollten eine
kommission genau für die parität und die
haben sie abgelehnt
ich sage ihnen wir wissen aus eigener
arbeit wie als grüne was es heißt
paritätische strukturen zu haben und wir
werden nicht nachlassen dafür zu kämpfen
dass parität auch in allen parlamenten
kommt meine damen und herren was es
braucht ist eine feministische regierung
die gleichstellung als zentrales
demokratie thema versteht und es
durchgängig im regierungshandeln umsetzt
und dazu gehört konsequentes gender
mainstreaming gender budgeting und wie
wir es in unserem grünen-antrag
geschlechtergerecht aus der krise schon
lange gefordert haben
wie das konkret aussehen kann zeigt die
neue beiden harry
administration das weiße haus macht
gleichstellung jetzt zur chefsache und
schafft einen sender policy council in
jedem haus gibt es verantwortliche die
über ihre messbaren anstrengungen für
die weiterentwicklung der gender
gerechtigkeit innerhalb der ministerien
dem sender policy council bericht
erstatten
darüber liegt ein plan zur bekämpfung
der schlächter basierter gewalt und es
gibt ebenso einen zur verbesserung der
arbeitsbedingungen für frauen und was
sich bemerkenswert finde ein besonderer
fokus liegt auf der finanzierung für
care arbeitet bei der umsetzung des
programms zur wirtschaftlichen erholung
nach der pandemie mit diesem plan werden
care berufe in der form ernst genommen
wie sie es in der usa in den usa aber
auch weltweit verdient hätten
und ich frage sie wo ist ihr plan zur
bekämpfung und zur begleitung des
strukturwandels nach der korona krise wo
sind ihre antworten auf die frage wie
wir verhindern können dass frauen zu
verliererinnen dieser pandemie werden es
ist so bitter für die frauen nach all
diesen versprechen aber ich sage und ich
erkenne ihnen fehlt der wille solche
pläne zu haben und umzusetzen hier
klafft eine ganz große lücke und das ist
echt frustrierend für die frauen in
diesem land
meine damen und herren eine unsere
antworten als grüne auf die drängenden
fragen in den letzten jahren und
besonders unter corona lautet der
häufigste women fix bi system also
reparieren nicht die frauen sondern das
system
denn darum geht es liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir werden alles dafür tun die
strukturellen hindernisse die es noch
gibt aus dem weg zu räumen wirksame
entgeltgleichheit stadt entgelt
transparenz wirksame frauenquoten stadt
unverschämte zielgrößen 0 oder thomas
kultur parität in den parlamenten
der wirtschaft der kultur statt mutlosen
stillstand und modelle für arbeitszeiten
die die vereinbarkeit für frauen und
männer ermöglichen und nicht behindern
und endlich schluss mit dem
selbstverständnis frauen die
zuständigkeit bei der sorge von kindern
und pflege zuzuschreiben
ich sage ihnen die zeit für überkommene
rollenbilder und die zeit in der über
frauen hinten über in der über frauen
hinweg gegangen werden kann die ist
vorbei es ist zeit für einen großen
bogen
wir müssen ran ans patriarchat es gibt
viel zu gewinnen und zwar für alle
vielen dank
jetzt hat das wort die bundesministerin
für frauen und senioren familie und
jugend franziska giffey
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren brauhaus ich
muss kurz darauf eingehen denn wir haben
etwas gemacht was sie immer gern tun in
diesen debatten sie greifen die an die
sich am meisten dafür einsetzen dass wir
verbesserungen erreichen und leben nicht
im scheinwerfer auf die verbesserungen
verhindern
und ich will ihnen ganz klar sagen wenn
sie fragen wo ist unser plan dann haben
wir als bundesregierung zum aller ersten
mal in der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland eine gleichstellung
strategie eine ressortübergreifende
gleichstellung strategie verabschiedet
die genau diesen plan beinhaltet und
wenn sie über gender wolle sie council
in amerika sprechen dann würde ich doch
empfehlen einfach auch mal zu schauen
was unsere gleichstellungsbeauftragten
in allen ressorts in allen bereichen auf
allen ebenen schon heute erreichen
welcher wir haben immer noch
entwicklungspotenziale das ist doch gar
keine frage
und wir setzen uns dafür ein dass dinge
besser werden aber ich will heute schon
noch mal den fokus darauf legen was wir
auch erreicht haben wir wollen
anerkennung für die frauen weil es
unheimlich viele frauen gibt die die
menschheit die unsere gesellschaft
voranbringen und vorangebracht haben
gerade jetzt in der pandemie ist das
sichtbar frauen halten an vielen stellen
den laden am laufen egal wo und sie
verdienen respekt das ist ganz klar wir
haben vieles erreicht dabei viel ist es
auch noch zu tun sie haben angesprochen
heute die aufwertung der sozialen berufe
die besseren löhne ausbildungs und
arbeitsbedingungen der kampf für
entgeltgleichheit zwischen männern und
frauen dessen konkrete dinge mit denen
wir uns intensiv ist
beschäftigen der kampf gegen gewalt an
frauen zum aller ersten mal gibt es in
dieser legislatur überhaupt ein
aktionsprogramm gegen gewalt an frauen
ausgestattet mit finanziellen mitteln um
eine länder aufgabe zu unterstützen
nämlich den ausbau der frauenhäuser und
der beratungsstelle und wir wollen die
sichtbarkeit von frauen erhöhen indem
wir sie eben bringen die
entscheidungspositionen des landes in
dem wir nicht einfach akzeptieren dass
nur zehn prozent der frauen in den
vorständen der großen unternehmen sind
dass wir viel zu wenige frauen auch in
den körperschaften des öffentlichen
rechts in den behörden und an vielen
vielen stellen auch der
zivilgesellschaft haben deshalb bringen
wir das zweite führungspositionen gesetz
ja auch ein und das ist ein beitrag zur
führung wir haben gesehen freiwillig tut
sich nichts und es braucht gesetzliche
vorgaben dafür und wenn sie beklagen
dass sie sich wünschen ein
bundesinstitut für gleichen dann sage
ich ihnen noch mal wir werden nächste
woche im kabinett die formulierungshilfe
beschließen für die bundesstiftung
leichter und die wird kommen und da
können wir jetzt nicht klar zu kommen
sondern sich freuen dass sie kommt ich
freue mich jedenfalls darauf und ich
finde es richtig seit über 100 jahren
kämpfen frauen für gleichberechtigung
wir sie hatten ganz andere
ausgangsbedingungen nämlich nicht das
wahlrecht wir hatten männer klubs gegen
die frauenemanzipation die sich
gegründet haben wir haben die vielleicht
auch heute noch nicht offiziell
ich weiß es nicht aber wissen sie wir
müssen wir auch etwas im weg
geschehen ist und wir arbeiten an diesem
weg weiter und wir wollen eine moderne
partnerschaftliche
gleichstellungspolitik die auf
vereinbarkeit setzt sie darauf setzt das
mädchen und jungen gleichermaßen sich
auch entscheiden können für den weg den
sie leben wollen
leider sind meine drei minuten um wir
kämpfen dafür lassen wir uns das
gemeinsam tun mit zuversicht und
tatkraft vielen dank nikolov schreibe
ich dir nicht mehr drin
[Applaus]
präsident werte kollegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren
frauenrechtlerinnen haben in den
vergangenen jahrhunderten die
gleichberechtigung erstritten und männer
haben sie in den parlamenten gewährt
dafür kommt ihnen für immer den dank der
nachfolgenden generationen zu leider ist
in unserer ach so basierten gesellschaft
auf der aus dem kampf für die frau
längst ein kampf gegen die biologische
frau geworden multikulturellen aber vor
allem auch ideal zur bigotterie der
installation des gewalttätigen steinzeit
patriarchats in deutschland wurde alles
gesagt
nichts scheint heutzutage
verachtenswerte als eine klassische
familie in der die frau einfach nur treu
sorgende mutter ist dabei ist dies ein
uhr gewaltiger topos in kunst literatur
und religion der im innersten der
meisten menschen liebevoll im gedanken
an die eigene mutter wieder halt für die
schöne neue welt der amtierenden
frauenrechtlerinnen muss das bild der
mutter weichen und zwar dem bild von
frauen und anderen gebärfähigen personen
die bei schwangerschaft körper
körperflüssigkeiten oder körperteile für
mindestens neun monate zur verfügung
stellen wie gestern dem antrag der
linken unter großer zustimmung von spd
und grünen propagiert wurde
für die marxisten aller couleur gilt
anscheinend die mutter ist tot es lebe
der gebärfähige körper das ist meine
damen und herren ist zutiefst war
eigentlich
frau wohnt die gnade ihnen leben
schenken zu können und die tiefsten und
innigsten beziehungen bindungen stiften
zu können die es auf der welt gibt
nämlich die zwischen müttern und ihren
kindern diese sollen zugunsten einer
unbedingten beruflich kite überwunden
werden
die lissabon strategie der eu besagt
bereits frauen die nicht lohnabhängig
erwerbstätig sind sind steuerlich
schlicht ungenutztes humankapital wenn
diese von ihrer eigenen hat natur
zutiefst entfremdeten leute an der macht
bleiben werden aus frauen langfristig
körperteile und körperflüssigkeiten mit
steuernummern immer dazu verdammt mit
männern gleichgestellt werden zu müssen
ein humanistischer offenbarungseid
und weil sie in den augen ihrer eigenen
geschlechtsgenossinnen und setze ich bin
nachteil liegt und anscheinend zu doof
sind ihre eigenen füße zu finden
beschert frau in die quote ein
bärendienst aber auch die quoten debatte
und das busen zählen sind virtuose
schatten boxkämpfe von feministinnen die
spüren dass ihre zeit abgelaufen ist
neue werte konservative
frauenrechtlerinnen braucht das land sie
treten ein mit allem was sie haben für
das frauenrecht nicht ständig mit
männern konkurrieren zu müssen und die
wahlfreiheit zu haben ob sie
erwerbstätig und oder hausfrau und
mutter sein wollen vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächste gegnerin ist die
staatsministerin im kanzleramt eine die
widmann mauz
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen der
internationale frauentag entstand vor
mehr als 100 jahren und frauen eine
stimme zu geben ich bin stolz darauf
dass es hier im deutschen bundestag und
überall in unserem land starke
selbstbewusste frauen gibt die ihren weg
gehen und ihre rechte einfordern
und das ist auch bitter nötig wenn ich
gerade in ihre richtung blicke sie von
der afg sie liegen dort mit ihrem
frauenbild 100 mehr als 100 jahre zurück
es mag ja noch länder geben in denen sie
sich mit diesem weltweit zu hause fühlen
aber gott sei dank
es werden von jahr zu jahr weniger und
genf
auch bei uns bleibt noch einiges zu tun
zum beispiel wenn es um die gewalt gegen
frauen die seit jahren sind die zahlen
hier auf einem hohen niveau
sexualisierter hass und frauenfeindliche
hetze sind im netz gegenwärtig auch im
übrigen gegenüber ihre kolleginnen hier
im hohen haus und damit dürfen wir uns
nicht abfinden und einige haben den
kampf dagegen ja auch bereits
erfolgreich angegangen und geklagt das
gelingt aber nur dann wenn der täter
sich ermitteln lässt ohne kenntnis der
ip adresse ist das im netz oft gar nicht
möglich
die bundesregierung hat das gesetz gegen
hasskriminalität auf den weg gebracht
allerdings verhindern grüne und fdp im
bundesrat dass es auch in kraft treten
kann
geben sie ihre blockade im
vermittlungsausschuss bei der
bestandsdaten auf auskunft endlich auf
datenschutz wird sonst zum täterschutz
und das wollen sie doch auch ernsthaft
nicht
ich bin unseren innenminister dankbar
dass unsere initiative aufgenommen hat
frauenfeindliche straftaten in den
polizeistatistiken hervorziehen
wir müssen gewalt gegen frauen erkennen
sie benennen und bekämpfen und auch hier
gilt mehr transparenz hilft wir brauchen
insgesamt mehr sichtbarkeit auf die
lebenswirklichkeit von frauen und das
hat uns corona schonungslos gezeigt als
im letzten jahr die bordelle schließen
mussten zeigte sich doch einmal mehr das
ganze elend von frauen in der
prostitution
die große mehrheit dieser frauen gerät
aus purer not drogenabhängigkeit oder
durch labors in diesen teufelskreis
viele sind migrantinnen unter falschen
versprechungen hierher gelockt
verschleppt gehandelt die ware aber
nicht behandelt wie menschen mit würde
nur einzelnen gelingt es auszubrechen
die meisten schweigen aus angst und
leiden ihr leben lang und
den psychischen und gesundheitlichen
folgen wir in der unionsfraktion wollen
das so nicht länger hinnehmen wir
verschließen unsere augen nicht wir
wollen prostituierte besser schützen
zwangsprostitution gezielt bekämpfen und
effektive ausstiegsangebote machen und
dafür haben wir konkrete vorschläge
erarbeitet
lassen sie uns doch noch wirksame
maßnahmen gegen die schlimmsten
auswüchse auf den weg bringen lassen sie
uns doch effektive aufstiegs angebote
machen der weltfrauentag wäre dafür der
ideale startpunkt er steht für handeln
gegen gewalt für gerechtigkeit und für
die gleichberechtigung von millionen von
frau wir wissen gesetze sind es 1
entscheidend ist dass sie etwas in
unserem bewusstsein unserer gesellschaft
anstoßen ein gleichberechtigtes
wertschätzendes miteinander beförderung
es gilt im umgang im parlament im
übrigen genauso wie in der öffentliche
debatte der unternehmenskultur und in
den familien
wer partnerschaftlich und fair
miteinander umgeht der kommt auch besser
durch schwierige zeit
wir wollen keine rolle rückwärts bei der
aufteilung von sorgearbeit und
erwerbsarbeit in den familien wir wollen
familien stärken und ein
gleichberechtigtes ein starkes
miteinander
deshalb haben wir den partnerschafts
bonus beim elterngeld verbessert deshalb
bauen wir auf die kinderbetreuung und
wir bauen sie weiter aus wir setzen auf
einen rechtsanspruch auf
ganztagsbetreuung an den grundschulen
und jahr für die frauen in der cdu steht
fest auch die steuerklasse 5 muss
abgeschafft werden damit frauen nicht
nur mehr netto vom brutto sondern auch
in der krise mehr arbeitslosen
kurzarbeiter kranken und elterngeld
erhalt mehr leistungsgerechtigkeit
bringt auch mehr sicherheit hier müssen
wir ran
denn es lohnt sich diese gesellschaft
auf gleichberechtigte schultern zu
stellen vielen dank
[Applaus]
dieter janzen fdp ist die nächste
rednerin
[Applaus]
der geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich kann mich
noch erinnern an die debatte hier vor
einem jahr wir haben darüber einen wohl
werk gesprochen darüber dass wir als
gesellschaft rückschritte in sachen
gleichberechtigung machen und damals
sprachen wir über diesen berg als einen
subtilen schleichenden prozess eine
langsame trendwende die man umkehren
muss doch die panini hat diesem rohrberg
einen zeitraffer verpasst laut einer
aktuellen studie des diw hat sich der
anteil der familien in denen die mutter
sich quasi allein um die kinder kümmert
fast verdoppelt krankenschwestern
pfleger wendeten kassiererin haben den
systemrelevanten berufen in erster reihe
im kampf gegen die pandemie gestanden
und sich im nachhinein nach der schicht
noch um homeschooling und haushalt
gekümmert
das letzte jahr hat uns dramatisch vor
augen geführt dass die errungenschaften
der gleichberechtigung nicht nur langsam
rotieren können sondern dass viel von
dem was mutige frauen in den letzten
jahrzehnten für uns erstritten haben für
mich erstritten haben mit einmal
zerbrechen kann und das führt uns diese
pandemie gerade hart vor augen und die
frage ist doch jetzt liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen akzeptieren wir das
ich sage nein wir freie demokraten sagen
nein wir sagen jetzt erst recht müssen
wir uns dafür einsetzen für
gleichberechtigung zu kämpfen
und glücklicherweise aber hat das
vergangene jahr natürlich nicht nur die
pandemie zu uns gebracht sondern auch
neue kunden und zwar weltweit
mit canale harris gibt es erstmals eine
vize präsidentin der vereinigten staaten
svetlana tief allofs kaya maria kohl s
nikkor war
die haben einen diktator vor augen
geführt was es heißt wenn man
kontrahentinnen unterschätzt und den
willen einer zivilgesellschaft in
belarus für freiheit zu kämpfen
am ersten berg
am ersten märz diesen jahres traten
busuu.com juni viana das schiff in den
abend der welthandelsorganisation an in
saudi arabien setzt sich lucas luhr
weiter für die rechte ihrer
mitbürgerinnen ein nicht nur fahren zu
können sondern viel viel mehr
obwohl erst vor kurzem ihr 1000 tägiges
martyrium endete als politische
gefangene sie aber nach wie vor ihr land
nicht verlassen darf
und schließlich hat die deutsche spitzen
wissenschaftlerin mosley präsident türe
che der welt den ersten corona impfstoff
beschert doch es gibt nicht nur meine
damen und herren es gibt nicht nur diese
großen ikonen die in der öffentlichkeit
stehen jeder von uns kennt sie die
helden und vorbilder unseres alltags und
für mich sind das zum beispiel frauen
wie grit petzold die bei uns im
schleswig holstein ein pflegeheim für
demenzkranke leitet und den menschen mit
viel kreativität und hingabe ein
größtmögliches maß an freiheit und würde
bietet für mich sind dass frauen wie die
erzieherinnen in der kita in kiel die
sich um meine tochter kümmern liebevoll
und dazu beitragen dass ich ein
selbstbewusster mensch wird und es sind
für mich frauen wie meine mutter die in
der notambulanz in husum arbeiten
teilweise in arbeits quarantäne und
dennoch jedem einzelnen patienten
hundertprozentige aufmerksamkeit schenkt
sie alle meine damen und herren
sie alle haben etwas gemeinsam sie alle
inspirieren menschen um sich herum und
sie alle zeigen das potenzial das in
unserer gesellschaft liegt das potenzial
von frauen große aber auch kleine
veränderungen anzustrengen und unser job
hier im bundestag ist es jeder einzelne
von ihnen zu ermöglichen genau dort zu
wirken wo sie ihr potenzial sieht denn
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wenn
männer und frauen sich einsetzen für
frauen wenn männer und frauen seite an
seite für frauen kämpfen dann gewinnen
nicht nur die frauen sondern gehen wir
alle und ich glaube das ist ja ein ziel
dass alle von uns ein
herzlichen dank jetzt hat es war die
kollegin katja kipping die linie
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
heute vor 150 jahren wurde rosa
luxemburg geboren ihr wirken zeigt ganz
klar dass man sozialen fortschritt nicht
auf dem silbertablett präsentiert
bekommt sondern ihn sich erkämpfen muss
und von luxemburg stammt der begriff der
sozial garantien des lebens die korona
krise hart und schmerzhaft vor augen
geführt wie wichtig heute im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert soziale
garantien sind die alles sicher vor
armut schützen
und natürlich sind alle geschlechter von
armut betroffen doch wir wissen frauen
besonders nicht nur am frauentag sagen
jeder linken deshalb im bedarfsfall darf
kein mensch kein mann und keine frau im
monat unter 1200 euro fallen da lassen
wir nicht locker denn wir wollen eine
welt frei von armut immer noch besetzten
männer ein großteil der über bezahlten
spitzenjobs und frauen tragen einen
großteil der unbezahlte familienarbeit
bzw
der unterbezahlten sorgearbeit zb in der
pflege weg und für ihre aufopferung
werden sie dann mit niedrigeren renten
im alter und mit weniger einfluss auf
entscheidungen politik und wirtschaft
gestraft das müssen wir ändern es ist
höchste zeit für eine mission trifft die
fifty also den aufbruch in eine
gesellschaft wo die verschiedenen
tätigkeiten zwischen den geschlechtern
gerecht verteilt sind die spitzenjobs
wie die wunderbare familienarbeit
die gute nachricht ist egal was jetzt
von rechts kommt für feministinnen und
feministen haben den wind der geschichte
in unseren segeln und all jenen die mit
dieser zeit noch etwas fremdeln den rufe
ich zu
die geschlechtergerechtigkeit wird
kommen wollt ihr da wirklich an der
seitenlinie der geschichte stehen
bleiben wir für ministerinnen laden alle
eingeladen euch ein euch auch mit all
euren bedenken produktiv einzubringen
und an dessen fortschritt mitzuwirken es
ist ein fortschritt der nicht
aufzuhalten ist denn wir werden unser
kämpfen vielen dank nächste redner
indische kollege danny breymaier ist
begeben
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
liebe frau ministerin gefallen wir haben
in diesem jahr mehrere landtagswahlen
und auch die bundestagswahl und
bezüglich der zusammensetzung dieser
parlamente rechne ich im jahr 2021 nicht
mit wundern
der anteil der frauen in den neu
zusammengesetzten parlamenten die dieses
jahr gewählt werden wird sich nicht
spürbar erhöhen und doch bin ich
perspektivisch hoffnungsvoll warum
erstens weil katja mast jahrzehnte
frauen ausgerufen hat zweitens weil ich
sicher bin dass wir auf der strecke in
diesen zehn jahren 1 parität gesetz auch
für den deutschen bundestag schaffen und
zwar verfassungsfest ich bin mit dem
jüngsten beschluss in kauf ruhe insofern
sehr zufrieden weil er mich in dieser
position bestärkt hat denn es hat eben
nicht wie regelmäßig von der rechten
seite des
es ist eingeworfen wird gesagt parits
gesetze widersprechen dem grundgesetz
übrigens geht es in thüringen und
brandenburg um die landesverfassungen
und diese entscheidungen liegen auch in
haus hall zur überprüfung des
bundesverfassungsgericht hat die jüngst
anträge verbrauchen die zweifel an der
legitimität der bundestagswahl 2017
hatten und 2017 so das gericht gab es
keinen verstoß gegen aktuell bestehende
vorschriften durch das
bundesverfassungsgericht sagt sehr klar
und erfreulich ausführlich die
ausgestaltung des wahlrechts hat der
verfassungsgebung offen gelassen und dem
bundesgesetzgeber überlassen
die art mit der auftrag aus acht liebe 3
absatz 2 satz 2 grundgesetz der staat
fördert die tatsächliche
gleichberechtigung von frauen und
männern und wirkt auf die beseitigung
bestehender nachteile hin also die art
wie der konkrete auftrag an den
gesetzgeber darauf beim wahlrecht
erfüllt wird obliegt dem
gesetzgeberischen ermessen was heißt das
wenn wir uns hier für ein parität gesetz
entscheiden kann man davon ausgehen dass
das bundesverfassungsgericht und ich
habe keinen zweifel dass es da landen
wird dass das gericht also sagte
gesetzgeber hat hier seinen job gemacht
also sorgen wir dafür dass zum jüngsten
beschluss kein dummes zeug verbreitet
wird sondern erst in der
rechtskommission in einem
gesetzgeberischen verfahren die
grundlagen dafür gelegt werden dass der
frauenanteil im deutschen bundestag dem
frauenanteil in der bevölkerung
entspricht warum eigentlich weil der
alltag die erfahrungen das leben der
frauen mehr in unsere debatten und
unsere entscheidungen einfließen müssen
wir brauchen alle talente mehr frauen in
die parlamente
so hätten kleine aktuellen
weil der letzte woche ist so eine
komische entscheidung der caritas und
eine nicht entscheidung der diakonie zur
kenntnis genommen haben
ich bin es wirklich schwierig wenn ihr
ein jahren die heldinnen des alltags die
helden in der pflege bejubeln und dann
caritas und diakonie verhindern dass wir
im bereich der altenpflege einen
allgemeinverbindlichen tarifvertrag
und ich sage auch als kind als mit die
evangelischen kirchen von einer kirche
etwas anderes besten dank für die
aufmerksamkeit und einen kämpferischen
frauentag sabine zimmermann die linke
ist die nächste gerät
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren warum begehen wir den
internationalen frauentag nicht nur für
politikerinnen und aufsichtsrätinnen
sondern für millionen frauen mit ganz
normalen arbeitsverhältnissen für sie
haben die sozialistinnen und sozialisten
1911 den internationalen frauentag ins
leben gerufen
und für diese interessen der großen
mehrheit der frauen setzen wir uns
zeigen und dafür kämpft die linke damals
ging es vor allem um das frauenwahlrecht
heute geht es ums ganze
deshalb fordern wir
gleichstellungspolitik darf nicht am
werk vor aufhören meine damen und herren
was heißt das ganz konkret jede vierte
frau arbeitet zum niedriglohn es geht
aber nicht nur um gleicher lohn für
gleiche arbeit es geht darum dass arbeit
die mehrheitlich von frauen verrichtet
wird in unserer gesellschaft weniger
wert ist pflege erziehung
dienstleistungen was man von frauen
sonst umsonst erwartet wird auch im
arbeitsleben schlecht bezahlt diesem
überholte denkmuster sagen wir den kampf
an liebe frauen selbst die
bundesregierung hat erkannt mich
bankvorstände und wirtschaftsbosse
sondern pflegerinnen und pfleger
erzieherinnen und erzieher
verkäuferinnen und verkäufer sind
systemrelevant aber warum haben sie dann
solche niedrigen löhne und gehälter
meine damen und herren warum besteht ihr
arbeitsleben aus dauerstress und
arbeitseinsätzen auf zuruf die linke
fordert mit dieser ausbeutung muss
endlich schluss sein
wir fordern mehr anna k
in euro und cent daran werden wir bei
jeder tarifauseinandersetzung erinnern
wir fordern einerseits eine kürze
vollzeit andererseits schluss mit
unfreiwilliger teilzeit planbare
arbeitszeiten in der praxis nicht nur
auf dem papier
kurzarbeit die 2021 zum leben passt für
frauen und für männer und meine damen
und herren gleichstellung und
arbeitsmarkt achter märz und erster mai
das gehört zusammen genau dafür steht
die linke meine damen und herren und ich
wünsche ihm allen einen kämpferischen
erst 8 märz dankeschön war schon acht
mal ging aber auf die bühne
marcus weinberg cdu csu durch die
nächste redner
[Applaus]
vielen dank herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen tatsächlich ist
eine bestandsaufnahme wichtig in dieser
zeit und kolleginnen hat gesagt jetzt
erst recht dann muss man tatsächlich
wenn man die andere reeder in sorge
seien über das was wir als erwägt
entwicklung möglicherweise vor uns haben
bei der bestandsaufnahme geht es um zwei
dinge wir machen das weil wir einen
auftrag haben wir haben einen
grundgesetzlichen auftrag nämlich
artikel 3 sagt wir sind verpflichtet die
tatsächliche durchsetzung der
gleichberechtigung von frauen und
männern zu fördern das ist der auftrag
unseres handelns es ist übrigens auch
eine moralische auftrag und dafür muss
man eine haltung haben einen
menschenbild haben und ein frauenbild
haben und ich glaube das hat sich heute
wieder bewiesen da haben einige noch
einhaltung problem richtig ist bei den
rahmenbedingungen liebe kollegin chance
bei den rahmenbedingungen haben wir den
letzten jahren mit ihren
koalitionsvertrag vieles verändert das
thema gewalt gegen frauen oder neu
aufgerufen wir haben gerade das thema
prostitution auch heute hier in der
debatte gehört und die gleichstellung
stiftung wird kommen und wir werden auch
dass frauen und führungspositionen
gesetz zwei verankern richtig aber
richtig ist auch dass hier noch vieles
vor uns haben und wenn ich sage das hat
etwas mit haltung zu tun
dann muss man auch gewisse
gesellschaftliche gruppen in die
pflichten entscheiden hat immer noch
mehr buchstaben als sein und ankündigung
der wirtschaft sind zunächst einmal nur
ankündigung und da muss man sich fragen
was wurde denn liefert man muss dinge
wollen und tun wenn 78 prozent der
unternehmen eine zielgröße von 0
formulieren dann ist das keine
vernünftige haltung mit blick auf die
förderung von frauen in
führungspositionen und wenn sie diese an
frau kollegin an der afg wir machen
frauen bei diesen debatten zu opfern
dann müssen wir uns auch die reale
lebenssituation an
nehmen sie die gesundheitsbranche 75
prozent der mitarbeiterinnen sind frauen
schauen sich die vorstände in diesem
bereich an bei den zehn grössten
krankenkassen von 24 posten sind zwei
mit frauen besetzt das ist eine
schieflage die für uns auch nicht
akzeptabel ist und deswegen sagen wir
auch ganz deutlich stichwort quoten und
kuren ich bin kein überzeugter anhänger
von quoten aber quoten haben eine
aufgabe und ein ziel sich selbst
abzuschaffen wir eines tages und so
sagen wir diesen auftrag nach dem
grundgesetz nicht erfüllt haben müssen
wir auch darüber nachdenken und das tun
wir auch guten einzuführen
denn da muss man mit gewissen minuten
mal auf eurem leistungs quoten wären
nicht leistungsfördernd wissen sie wir
reden gerade über unternehmen den blick
auf das thema frauen in
führungspositionen darin über 26
unternehmen der anteil von frauen in
vorständen beträgt dort 14,8 prozent
wer mir ernsthaft einer sagen dass
frauen mit blick auf die kognitiven
emotionalen und sozialen fähigkeiten
diese 14,8 prozent verdient haben nein
und deswegen werden wir jetzt auch im
bereich der frauen in führungspositionen
diese quote einführen und umsetzen und
der zweite müde ist es dann diese
features branchenspezifisch ich kann
mich erinnern als er darüber diskutiert
haben frauen in aufsichtsräten da wurde
mir gesagt aber er war in der
stahlindustrie das sind alles stahlbauer
das können nur männer das können doch
keine frauen seien und dann guckt man
sich nicht an dem aufsichtsrat was haben
denn diese männer für einen beruf das
waren juristen und kann nichts anderes
und deswegen muss man auch mit diesem
mythos der branche mal aufräumt genauso
die sicherlich mit einem verhinderung
auch geraten der politik und da können
wir uns an die teilweise sehr große
eigene nase fassen
auch wie in der politik und es ist
teilweise noch nicht gelungen das thema
richtig anzugehen wenn es dann heißt ja
aber alle quote würde ja dann verhindern
dass die guten männer des jeweiligen
distrikt des ortsverbandes oder wo auch
immer nicht zum zuge kommen ja wir
kümmern uns darum dass ober- unter- berg
und oberberg oberberg und unter
unterberg alle gut vertreten sind das
ist das regionalprinzip die regional
quote aber bei den frauen wäre dann kein
quatsch mehr auch da muss man mit diesem
mythos mal aufräumen
auch da brauchen wir etwas stringentere
vorgehensweisen und dann zum schluss ist
sicherlich die wie ich finde verteilt
sich der fatale zum mythos dieser
vereinbarkeit mythos für wahlfreiheit
die freiheit der familie schützen wir
aber wir müssen uns rahmenbedingungen
setzen das auch wirklich freiheit
existiert und die haben wir erst dann
wenn wir weitere arbeit im bereich
ausbau der kindertagesbetreuung im
bereich ausbau der ganztagsbetreuung
wenn wir die rahmenbedingungen für
familien insgesamt verbessern dann wenn
du hoffentlich eines tages das erreichen
was übrigens norden erreicht hat
ein sieger der krisenzeit nording
meisterte krisen am besten norwegen hat
man seit 2006 eine quote 41 prozent der
positionen in der wirtschaft sind mit
frauen besetzt um 44% der position in
den parlamenten sinne frauen besetzt und
das läuft in nordrhein
das war für norwegen erfolgreich wenn
das ist das was wir auch in deutschland
brauchen endlich diesen artikel 3
umgesetzt sagte wenn wir auch weiter
kämpfen mit vielen kleinen maßnahmen
einer klaren haltung und guten
rahmenbedingungen vielen dank
[Applaus]
jetzt zeigt das wort den
bundesaußenminister heiko maas herr
präsident meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
während die welt gegen des corona virus
kämpft ist etwas im gange was bei den
vereinten nationen als die schatten
pandemie bezeichnet wird und das ist der
weltweite roll back von frauen von
frauenrechten und deshalb meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren wir haben in
der debatte jetzt schon viel gehört von
franziska giffey und anderen was das in
unserem eigenen land bewirbt an
rollenbildern die wieder aufgenommen
aber auch an anderen themen die es
wieder gibt in verstärktem maße wie etwa
häusliche gewalt
und wenn man das was uns bei uns
geschieht
zigmal ausmalt wie das wirkt in
entwicklungsländern oder
konfliktgebieten wo frauen und mädchen
dem völlig ungeschützt ausgesetzt sind
dann muss man feststellen
dort geht es nicht um
selbstverwirklichung sondern dort geht
es ganz banal um leben und tod
und deshalb meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren frauenrechte haben eine
internationale komponente deshalb heißt
es ja auch der internationale frauentag
und deshalb haben wir unsere weltweite
unterstützung für frauen und mädchen
noch einmal intensiviert und zwar ganz
konkret sie reicht von safe hauses für
menschenrechtsverteidigerinnen in
afghanistan über verhandlungs trainings
für politikerinnen in khartum bis hin zu
frauen netzwerken in afrika und
lateinamerika im sicherheitsrat der
vereinten nationen haben wir dafür
gesorgt dass sexualisierte gewalt in
konflikten schärfer verfolgt wird als
das bisher bei den vereinten nationen
der fall gewesen ist und dass die rolle
von frauen in der krisenprävention
und bei friedensverhandlungen wo man
auch zu selten frauen trifft obwohl es
auch gerade dort um deren rechte in der
nach konflikt ära geht auch deren rolle
und soll dort verstärkt werden und nicht
zuletzt haben wir in der letzten woche
im kabinett den aktionsplan der
bundesregierung zur umsetzung der un
agenda frauen frieden sicherheit
verabschiedet
erstmals mit ganz verbindlichen
indikatoren um fortschritte auch selber
messen können und deshalb das muss man
sich bei der internationalen komponente
wirklich noch einmal deutlich vor augen
führen international in vielen regionen
dieser welt geht es gar nicht darum
frauenrechte auszubauen sondern es geht
ganz banal darum um dafür zu sorgen dass
es überhaupt welche gibt in der realität
und deshalb hat das nichts damit zu tun
so wie das hier zeitweise zu verstehen
gewesen ist dass es sicher mal
ideologisch getriebene das wohlfühl
thema hatte oder dass es darum geht das
eigenständige kulturen und gewachsene
strukturen dauerhaft verändert werden
soll
ja letzteres ist so letzteres ist es im
übrigen wie ich finde eine dauerhafte
aufgabe jeder gesellschaft strukturen
und kulturen zu überwinden wenn das
nicht der fall wäre würden wir alle noch
in der steinzeit leben und deshalb meine
damen und herren ich sage ganz offen ja
wir wollen auch bestimmte kulturen
überwinden wenn das bedeutet dass frauen
und mädchen nicht mehr als kriegswaffe
eingesetzt werden dass
genitalverstümmelung endlich aufhören
das gefährt gewaltigen nicht länger ein
instrument der kriegsführung sind das
hat nichts mit interventionismus oder
ideologie
zu tun es ist nichts anderes als die
universellen menschenrechte ernst zu
nehmen herzlichen dank
jean-marc was cdu/csu ist direkt darin
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
dieses jahr ist ein besonderes jahr wir
begehen den internationalen frauentag
inmitten einer weltweiten pandemie und
die bewältigung der korona pandemie ist
ein kraftakt für unser land
und zwar in allen bereichen aber frauen
und familien sind davon in besonderer
weise betroffen
für frauen steht kone synonym für eine
mehrfachbelastung aber frauen sind
meisterinnen darin solche belastungen
auch erfolgreich zu bewältigen
beispielsweise im home office home
schule und kinderbetreuung gleichzeitig
aber mit zunehmender dauer geraten auch
frauen und ihre familien an die grenzen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen frauen
tragen entscheidend dazu bei dass unser
land im vergleich zu anderen ländern das
durch die krise kommt wo wären wir ohne
die klugen ärztinnen und
wissenschaftlerinnen die erfolgreich das
virus bekämpfen
ich denke dabei an öffnen türen sie
kathrin janßen melanie brinkmann oder
doktor carola holz noch besser bekannt
als dr
sie sind beispiele von sehr vielen ihnen
und allen anderen frauen sagen wir am
internationalen frauentag danke
[Applaus]
wir sind aber jetzt an einem punkt in
der pandemie wo wir in die zukunft
schauen müssen uns fragen müssen welche
lehren ziehen wir aus gronau
welche chancen nutzen wir wir sollten
die krise nutzen um bei strukturellen
benachteiligung von frauen zu lösungen
zu kommen sei es beim verdienst bei der
sozialen absicherung oder auch bei der
anerkennung der arbeit
zwei beispiele möchte ich konkretisieren
zum 1 es wurde schon oft heute gesagt
ist in die sozialen berufe sie sind oft
frauenberufe und in unserem land
systemrelevant faire bezahlung ist ja
oft nicht selbstverständlich wir müssen
uns deshalb die lohnstruktur und leni
breymaier hat es gesagt die tarifbindung
in diesem bereich anschauen
beides muss im sinne der frauen gestärkt
werden
zweitens wir müssen auch die soziale
absicherung von selbstständigen
verbessern
viele solo selbstständige gerade im
kultur und mädchenbereich sind frauen
für sie ist die krise besonders prekär
und die eigenversorgung blieb oft auf
der strecke
die gefundene lösung des allein staaten
zugangs zur grundsicherung die trägt oft
nicht
familien sind damit oft die
leidtragenden
deshalb müssen wir für selbstständige
den zugang zur arbeitslosenversicherung
vereinfachen
in krisenzeiten sondern auch sie
kurzarbeitergeld erhalten können
ich könnte diese reihung noch vorführen
mit vielen vielen weiteren beispielen
sei es im hinblick auf den arbeitsplatz
haushalt der attraktiver gestaltet
werden muss oder auch auf den
mutterschutz anspruch für
vorstandsfrauen viele beispiele wurden
dazu heute schon angeführt die korona
pandemie hat aber auch was positives
bewirkt in kurzer zeit wurden
veränderungen möglich home office
die blaue bei zeit neue formen der
zusammenarbeit und kommunikation
hier liegen chancen und diese chancen
die wir für die gestaltung einer
attraktiven zukunftsorientierten
arbeitswelt auch weiter in zukunft
nutzen sollten die nutzung digitaler
formate allein statt zb ganz erheblich
die vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf
und somit auch die teilhabe von frauen
lasst uns dies auch nach corona
weiterführen
lasst uns die krise nutzen um
fehlentwicklungen zu korrigieren und
klein trächtigen in unserem land weiter
voranzubringen vielen dank
[Applaus]
voraussichtlich letzte rednerin in
dieser debatte ist die kollegin druck
dass ihr gelaunt cdu csu
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
damen und herren malaika zwölf jahre alt
wohnhaft in somalia malaika kann weder
lesen noch schreiben in wenigen tagen
soll sie einen mann heiraten der fünf
jahrzehnte älter ist als sie
sophie zwölf jahre alt wohnhaft in
deutschland so viel geht in die sechste
klasse auf die frage was sie einmal
werden möchte laut ihrer antwort ärzten
oder polizisten zwei mädchen zwei leben
zwei welten in eigenen lebensweg frei
wählen über den eigenen körper selbst
bestimmen ja die eigene meinung frei
äußern wünsche beziehungsweise forderung
die für uns hier in deutschland auf den
ersten blick alles selbstverständlich
sind wünsche die bei uns im grundgesetz
rechte sind ich wüsste sie nicht im
detail auf die situation von mareike und
vielen anderen mädchen und frauen
weltweit und wir haben heute den
internationalen frauentag weltweit ist
eine völlig andere
das kinderhilfswerk unicef schätzt dass
jährlich etwa zwölf millionen mädchen in
eine kinder je gezwungen werden darüber
hinaus gibt es rund 200 millionen frauen
und mädchen die opfer von
genitalverstümmelung werden und 34
millionen mädchen im grundschulalter die
keine schule besuchen zahlen die
fassungslos machen die uns vor augen
führen welches glück wir haben dass wir
hier in europa in deutschland leben
dürfen und ja auch hier ist nicht alles
effekt aber im großen und ganzen können
wir dankbar seien dankbar dass wir hier
leben können ein lebendes übrigens wir
uns nicht verdient haben es ein geschenk
gewesen dass wir hier der geburt geboren
worden sind und diese chancen hier haben
und am weltfrauentag müssen wir uns
dieser unterschiede und auch diese
errungenschaften der letzten jahrzehnte
bewusst werden
ich habe es gerade schon anklingen
lassen auch hier in deutschland ist
nicht alles gut
es gibt mehrere bereiche von vielen
kolleginnen ist angesprochen worden der
eine bereich ist die gewalt gegen frauen
es erschreckt mich immer wieder aber
fast jeden dritten tag wird in
deutschland eine frau von ihrem partner
oder ex-partner getötet ich freue mich
dass es angesprochen wurde von der frau
ministerin
denn wir haben nicht nur das helfe
telefon eingerichtet gewalt gegen frauen
sondern das erste mal auf eingestiegen
die förderung von frauenhäusern und es
ist nun mal so es ist keine bundessache
hat das erste mal gesagt wir nähern uns
diesen themen an
ich persönlich bin immer noch ein großer
fan davon nicht nur die frauenhäuser zu
stärken sondern die psychologische
ambulante beratung das halte ich noch
für einen besseren schritt auch
ländersache
auch da ist bei den ländern nicht
ansatzweise alles perfekt aber ich hoffe
und das ist auch unsere aufgabe immer
wieder darauf hinzuweisen eindruck zu
machen dass ich das verbessert wir haben
strafbarkeit geändert eine verschärfung
beim stalking von mir aus konnte das
ruhig noch ein bisschen mehr sein
eine verschärfung oder einführung der
strafbarkeit bei marx gehört in die
justizministerin ist ja da auch das sind
bereiche wo wir im bereich
alt gegen frauen einen wesentlichen
beitrag leisten von dem unschätzbaren
beitrag die strafbarkeit
vergewaltigungen der ehe nicht gar nicht
sprechen das gibt es in ganz ganz vielen
ländern der welt nicht
ein weiterer wichtiger bereich ist die
gleichstellung und da wurde heute auch
schon vieles angesprochen dass
führungspositionen gesetzt zwei haben
wir letzte woche beraten reform das
elterngeld haben erst vor wenigen wochen
da geht es um mehr flexibilität mehr
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf mehr
partnerschaftliche teilhabe den ausbau
der kinderbetreuung ist angesprochen
werden das gute kita gesetz ein
riesenbetrag an sich ist der bund auch
dafür nicht zuständig auch das auf den
weg gebracht das müssen wir auch sind
denn das ermöglicht erst die
wahlfreiheit der anspruch auf
ganztagsbetreuung denn wir wollen ganz
ehrlich ich verstehe beim besten willen
nicht wir wollen es die ganze zeit ist
der bund ist an sich für die
finanzierung den ausbau fordert deutlich
aber für die finanzierungs- und als
nicht zuständig ist es wieder bereit
mehr zu geben und das blockiert baden
württemberg und hessen ich verstehe
nicht warum die medien nicht voll sind
mit diesem thema dass hier ein ganz
wesentlicher beitrag für die mütter für
die frauen zu echten wahlfreiheit die so
gar nicht druck gemacht wird auf die
zuständigen ministerpräsidenten die
wollen doch wieder gewählt werden um
verständnis wir von der csu
wollen außerdem ihre pakete
vereinbarkeit insgesamt in angriff
nehmen
zwei elterngeld mona der extra wenn der
vater vielleicht vier monate zu hause
bleibt höchstarbeitszeit nicht pro woche
sollen pro tag damit für die frauen
flexible ist voller ärztekollegen
kinderbetreuungskosten und achten sie
bitte darauf sie sehen wir widmen uns
dem thema wir wollen frauen stärken und
das nicht nur am weltfrauentag sondern
auch zu anderen zeiten vielen dank damit
schließt sich die aussprache